so we surveyed nhs leaders and the vast
majority want us to be careful about the
way in which we try to move from
endemic
uh to back to normality so
uh eight out of ten uh nhs leaders would
like to see the continuation of free
tests 9 out of 10 want free tests for
care
staff
we don't want to see
the end of mandatory isolation if you've
had a positive test we've got down to
five days now but we still think it's
important
that people do uh isolate and we want
the continuation of wearing masks in
care settings and we want the government
to continue to undertake
regular research about the level of
prevalence of covid out in the community
so
our view is let's continue on an
evidence-based incremental way to move
from the pandemic to a situation where
we are living with kovid but let's not
act in a way which in not necessarily
increases risks or me all that means
that covert goes on for longer than it
needs to go on
has there been any suggestion that free
testing will end for healthcare workers
well we don't know it's been briefed uh
this week we won't know the government's
position until monday and so that's why
we asked our leaders this week in order
to get a strong message to the
government ahead of that announcement
and what we're saying is that it would
be a mistake to end uh free testing and
a particular mistake when free testing
for health service staff we have to
remember
that whilst we're in a much much better
position than we've been in before
because of the vaccine and because we
have much better treatments now for
people with covered it's still the case
that many people are getting sick with
this disease and that some people are
dying with this disease and particularly
those people who are vulnerable
it is still a big issue so let's move
gradually to where we need to get to and
let's allow the nhs to focus on what
it's starting to do which is working at
that huge backlog that built up during
coding
remaining careful of course i wonder if
the question was asked matthew taylor as
to at which point nhs leaders want to
see
some more normality in the healthcare
system
so i think we we want to just take this
step by step i think what worries us is
the idea that on monday there'll be a
kind of big bang
at the same time
we'll do a whole range of things each of
which on their own could increase risk
so if on monday we were to see
no more masks being required in clinical
settings no more free tests uh
potentially uh downgrading the the
quality of real-time research that we
have on code put all that together all
those issues together and there's a real
danger that we'll see an uptick in this
in this virus at a time when we want to
do is we want to focus on the kind of
day-to-day work of the health service so
you know we are in the nhs are as in
favor of everybody else of getting back
to normal a few weeks ago we welcomed
the reduction in the time period for
people being isolated
but but let's be evidence-based let's do
this step by step what we don't want is
to make us see a set of announcements
that look great on the day but that we
come to regret in the weeks and months
to come and let's not forget there are
still risks the combination of declining
immunity and the possibility of a new
variant that could mean that the
infrastructure we built around covered
will have to be used again
okay matthew taylor the chief exec of
the nhs confederation will wait uh
announcement on monday i'm sure we'll
speak to you again once we hear it thank
you very much for being with us this
morning